und damit der bundestag entscheiden kann
muss er wissen was die regierung dort
vor hat guten abend frau ministerin
haben sie schon eine vorstellung
ich möchte dass wir nicht tatenlos
zuschauen wenn wir auf den nordirak
schauen dort haben wir zurzeit eine ganz
ganz schwierige humanitäre situation der
kampf gegen den es ist quasi eingestellt
das betrifft unsere
sicherheitsinteressen massiv und ich
schlage vor und wünsche mir dass wir
eine international kontrollierte
schutzzone dort einrichten um den kampf
gegen den esv setzen zu können aber auch
um wiederaufbau zu leistende mit
menschen in ihrer heimat wieder
zurückkehren können
sie meinen den das gebiet in nordsyrien
in dem die türkei nun einmarschiert ist
das hat ihr kollege außenminister
gestern erst als völkerrechtswidrig
erklärt wenn jetzt deutschland und
andere in der region mitmischen wird es
dadurch automatisch völkerrechts gemäss
wir haben eine ganz klare betrachtung
was das verhalten der türkei anbelangt
die frage ist ja was ist eine mögliche
alternative die alternative dass die
türkei auf dauer in dieser region bleibt
um ihre interessen zu wahren macht das
thema völkerrecht noch sehr viel
schwieriger wir haben russland als einen
großen akteur in dieser region und
deswegen bin ich der auffassung wenn wir
möchten dass der dass der terror weiter
bekämpft wird wenn wir möchten dass
menschen freiwillig wieder in dieser
region zurückkehren können dann müssen
wir dort eine politische lösung
herbeiführen
und deswegen brauchen wir auch eine
internationale kontrolle und ein
internationales zusammenwirken und eben
gerade nicht nur das zusammenwirken
zwischen russland und der türkei
das heißt wir wollen mit russland und
der türkei sprechen wollen sie auch mit
syrien sprechen mit hamas ab
nein es geht zuerst einmal darum dass
wir aus europa heraus eine initiative
starten
die kanzlerin hat ja angekündigt dass
sie sich mit dem französischen
staatspräsidenten mit dem britischen
premierminister und auch mit dem
türkischen staatspräsidenten treffen
will
wir haben den deutsch-französischen
verteidigungs und sicherheitsrates
ich schlage vor dass wir den dazu
einladen die britischen kollegen und
dass wir von dort aus den vorschlag
machen wie eine solche
international kontrollierte zone
aussehen kann das ist sie erst einmal
nur die fragestellung für nordsyrien für
nichts weiteres für syrien selbst haben
wir eine resolution der vereinten
nationen und die gilt wer einen solchen
vorstoß unternimmt und das ist ja
ziemlich erstmalig dass deutschland ein
militärisch dominierten vorschlag
unternimmt der kann sich nicht auf dauer
vornehm zurückhaltend wie die deutschen
bisher die in syrien in tornados weit
oben oder auf fregatten weit draußen
waren und nun reden sie über einsatz am
boden einem gebiet aus dem die
amerikaner raus gegangen sind weil es
ihnen zu heiß geworden ist es geht
zuerst einmal darum dass wir natürlich
auch mit militärischen mitteln den kampf
gegen den es weiterführen das tun wir
mit unseren fähigkeiten der
luftüberwachung aber auch der ausbildung
zur zeit im irak
es geht aber vor allen dingen auch darum
dass wir politische stabilität dort
schaffen und dass dort wieder aufgebaut
werden kann etwas was wir im irak auch
tun wie eine internationale mission und
ein darauf aufbauendes mandat im
bundestag aussehen müsste das ist eine
entscheidung die der bundestag zu
treffen hat die bundeswehr wird immer
das zur verfügung stellen was die
politik von ihr verlangt nun geht mir
ein bisschen unter die einmaligkeit
dieser situation deutschland hat noch
nie eingegriffen in einem militärischen
konflikt wo im moment scharf geschossen
wird in einem heiß umkämpften gebiet und
übernimmt nun eine führungsrolle
wenigstens bei der vorbereitung dann
muss auch eine führungsrolle im
militärischen bereich folgen würde man
denken zuerst einmal geht es darum dass
wir auf der politischen und
diplomatischen ebene eine europäische
antwort geben können unter einbeziehung
natürlich auch der türkei und von
russland und in enger abstimmung mit den
vereinigten staaten ich bin der meinung
das steht uns gut an zumal in einer
woche in denen sich europäische
verteidigungsminister mit ihren kollegen
etwa aus den vereinigten staaten auch in
brüssel treffen werden
eine gute gelegenheit um das thema
anzusprechen im zuerst einmal geht es um
die politische initiative um die
politische lösung was dazu militärisch
aber auch im zivilen aufbau erforderlich
ist das ist der zweite schritt
und auch da muss man dann darüber reden
wie kann der beitrag deutschlands
aussehen
aber wir können nicht nur beklagen was
in dieser region passiert und als europa
keine antwort geben und wir sind einer
der stärksten partner in europa und
deswegen kommt es aus meiner sicht auch
auf uns an
nun sind sie aber bereit in diesem
ungewöhnlichen fall über das hinaus zu
gehen was deutsche soldaten in anderen
welt gebieten von afghanistan bis irak
bisher geleistet haben bei dieser
situation das erfordert zuerst einmal
was wir am ende des tages dort leisten
werden ist noch nicht entschieden das
ist entscheidungsgrundlage des
bundestages zum zweiten geht es vor
allen dingen darum dass wir eben auch
eine grundlage schaffen für einen
zivilen wiederaufbau denn wir müssen ja
sehen dass wir nicht nur eine massive
sicherheitsbedrohung haben durch die
freigelassenen ex kämpfer sondern dass
wir auch die situation haben das sehr
sehr viele menschen in dieser region auf
der flucht sind dass sie auch
angrenzende regionen destabilisieren das
alles betrifft die europäischen und auch
die deutschen interessen
und deswegen haben wir ein interesse
daran dass es eine politisch
dauerhaftere lösung für nordthüringen
gibt und wenn wir einen beitrag dazu
leisten können zuerst einmal politisch
und diplomatisch dann sollten wir das
tun
eine kleinigkeit noch zur koalition ist
es richtig dass sie den außenminister
von diesem vorstoß bei sms unterrichtet
habe ich habe ihn darüber informiert
dass sich als verteidigungsministerin
aber natürlich auch als cdu vorsitzende
die am wochenende beklagt hat dass es zu
wenig politische antworten gibt auch aus
der eigenen partei einen vorschlag
machen werde
und insofern sind wir darüber im
austausch alles weitere muss natürlich
auch in der koalition besprochen werden
aber mir war es wichtig in dieser woche
in der so viele gespräche laufen in der
morgen auch der waffenstillstand der
vereinbarte ausläuft auch eine
initiative zu starten und damit auch
deutschland aber auch europa ein
eine stimme zu geben sie haben also per
sms informiert wir sparen per sms in
kontakt
dankeschön und einen guten abend
bitteschön